Avengers end game co-director Joe Russo
has a few choice words for Oscar voters
critics are near unanimous in their
praise of the film and Robert Downey jr.
performance as Tony Stark
but if Russo were to have his way the
Marvel Cinematic Universe says biggest
star will take home an Academy Award for
the flick
according to the Washington Post heads
ur for some spoilers for Avengers
endgame ahead during a stop in a
nation's capital on a promotional tour
for the film late last week Russo didn't
hold back about the contributions a star
made not only to endgame but to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and popular
culture in general he explained his
cumulative body of work from these
movies is staggering if you look at the
work over just even the last four Marvel
films he's done is phenomenal he
deserves an Oscar perhaps more than
anyone in the last 40 years because of
the way that he has motivated popular
culture there have been a lot of great
film performances in the last 40 years
and Russo's making quite a bold
statement but he does have a point
Downey kicked off the entire MCU with
what was seen at the time as an
improbably brilliant performance in 2008
sigh oh man and since then he has added
layers of depth and complexity to a
character that could have been more
OneNote in the hands of a lesser actor
according to cinema blend his casting
was seen by industry analysts as a
gamble when it was announced in 2007 I
am Iron Man
in the decade leading up to his first
triumphant Turner stark Dalia struggled
heavily with alcohol abuse a poor public
image and a tendency to confuse and
alienate those around him all issues
which had plagued stark for years and
the pages of Marvel Comics now Russo and
his co-director brother Anthony Russo
believed Downey's work should be taken
into consideration by the Academy's
voters Anthony said he has a very
involved process a more involved process
in any actor we've ever worked with he
digs deeper and he works harder than
anybody Downey really just goes the
extra mile for everything it's like
everything he's doing is something to
his core Joe Russo also made the points
that the Academy seems to have an
inherent bias against popular movies in
the modern era compared to past Oscar
Best Picture winners like The Sound of
Music The Godfather and rocky to name
just a few
he added we're talking about some of the
most popular films ever made it feels
like there's now a prejudice against
popular cinema in a way that's somewhat
sad Downey has been nominated for Oscars
twice before once for the title role in
the 1992 biopic Chaplin and again for
his controversial comedic turn in 2008
strop ik Thunder but he permeates at the
role of Tony Stark with his own
personality and with Ben's game he
masterfully brought a close to an arc
that has taken over 10 years to complete
part of the journey yet
it seems almost inconceivable now but
when Marvel Studios chose to lead off
their Cinematic Universe with Iron Man
the character was so obscure that the
choice left industry analysts scratching
their heads in the lead-up to its
release Marvel even commissioned short
animated films intended to raise the
characters public profile today the
character is become a household name one
of the most popular in all of mainstream
cinema and it almost certainly would
never have happened if Downey had not
poured his heart and soul into the
character every time he stepped in front
of the cameras for Marvel over the last
decade Plus Downey has delivered an
acting performance unlike any in film
history and for that we agree that he
deserves his industry's highest honor
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loop of videos about
endgame and the MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]